hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of the Walking Dead Season
nine episode 11 titled bounty alphas
cruel survivalism in regards to a crying
baby lates that shows scariest sequence
in recent memory
Ezekiel Carol and Jerry set up some
major tears maybe and once again the
name of the game in the back half of
season 9 is begging teenage Henry not to
be a freaking idiot I'm gonna break it
all down the details that you might have
missed what this all means and how it
connects to the comics it's more the
warning in case you haven't seen the
episode yet and real quick before I
begin thanks to Philo for sponsoring
this video
stick around to the end of the video to
learn how you can start watching
episodes of The Walking Dead within
seconds and how you can get a month of
Philo content for free ok this episode
opens with a flashback to a few years
earlier sometime between rick's
departure and the time jump six years
later first clue we get to this time
madeleine is the opening image of
Ezekiel's clockface
I like the detail that the current time
is 9:11 as in this episodes number
season 9 episode 11 no I was gonna say
that this could be foreshadow me to a
new 911 that this season could be
setting up huh 911 isn't something you
should joke about and it always steers
the conversation into a depressing
vortex of where each of us were on the
day like I was in homeroom flags were
everywhere anyway Jerry's secret chat
with Ziggy leads to this great gag
reveal there's actually a third person
in this conversation Carol is kind of
like one of my favorite Arrested
Development ganks with Buster we also
know this must be earlier in the
timeline because Carol's hair is shorter
not yet the full Jamie Lee Curtis
Halloween 2018 Greymane and of course
Jesus is still alive this is apparently
the day Tara left Alexandre for the
hilltop taking some supplies with her
and they mention how Maggie's still in
charge of the hilltop and that she's not
happy with Michonne so again more hints
of some conflict between the communities
I'm thinking Michonne might have allowed
a new group to join and there was some
kind of coup in which several of them
had to surrender something to survive
kidneys now you don't make a next
incision to remove a kidney and think
sounds like we'll learn exactly what
went down between these communities in
episode 14 anyway we get our first look
at the Charter that was shown had begun
drafting at the start of this season
holds a Community Charter of Rights and
Freedoms when Michelle first proposes to
Rick after a visit in smithsonian a DC
she clarified that this would be a
charter not a Const
tution but you can see I'm shown
definitely model this on the US
Constitution but a same kind of font and
capitalization and a similar preamble
and article structure but rather than a
Constitution outlining how a central
government would be set up this shorter
reads more like a Bill of Rights which
was the list of the first ten amendments
that founding father James Madison added
to pacify states rights delegates and
the Constitutional Convention
similarly this list is designed for each
community to retain some autonomy and
protect individual liberties from any
dictatorship or rick tater ship but this
Charter was never signed to - probably
that mystery conflict between the
communities Ezequiel hopes that the
groups will come together and agree to
sign it in the upcoming fair but I'm not
feeling too good about that what do you
think Jerry yeah I'm not feeling too
good about it either
early on Ezekiel states as episodes
title own work to collect our bounty
bounty is of course the reward that you
receive for hunting an animal or a
person and in this episode we get a very
clear sense of the reward that many
people receive for hunting down many
precious items the main storyline is
adapted from a shoe 138 in the comics
when the whisperer leader alpha appears
to the hilltop gates to propose a
prisoner exchange to get back Lydia for
daughter in the comics the prisoners are
Dante and can hear it's alden Luke but
the real prize bounty of this storyline
isn't the super one trade between Alton
Luke and Lydia it's the whisper or baby
alpha orders that that baby be left to
die quoting natural selection even
though in the wild mothers fight
viciously to protect their young really
this is a demonstration by alpha to show
the hilltoppers just how savage they are
kind of like lighting on fire a $100
bill during a negotiation it's not about
the money it's about the message fear me
Luke slightly a sl's to Connie who
rescues the baby and it leads to this
terrifying chase through the cornstalks
this is so well directed seeing this all
from Connie's muffled perspective
resulted in each Walker appearance to
come off as a legit jump-scare it evokes
the way corn stalks and hedge mazes have
been used over time as creepy settings
movies like The Shining signs Field of
Dreams this baby ends up being a bounty
for the hilltop a new child for Tammy
rose and Earl to try to rebuild after
losing their son but this reward
required the concession of Lydia and in
order to convince Henry to give her up
Enid makes a call back to her JSS days
in the farewell letter that
all wrote for her last season in the
price that Darryl pays to give up Lydia
is his guilt for condemning a kid back
to abuse alpha even rubs it in by
immediately slapping Lydia right in
front of Darrell notice the little half
smile that she gives him Lydia is hers
to torment the other storyline is
episode follows Ezekiel Carol and Jerry
hunting a parallel bounty a cinema
projector bulb now this is some clever
symbolism by the show a projector bulb
like a baby is fragile but also a source
of light and inspiration a window to a
different time and yeah both babies and
bulbs are bulbous this sequence is also
super well designed
notice how the walkers are bent up by a
popcorn machine and the tension of the
sequence builds up to a climax of the
walkers spilling over the way popcorn
spills out from a kettle outside when
the movie posters on the wall is a movie
called antagony which is a term we don't
really use it anymore it's a noun form
of antagonize perhaps a play on words
with agony it's derived from the Greek
figure Antigone the main character from
the Greek play about a woman who defies
the king because she wants to properly
bury her brothers and his conflict leads
to her suicide and the death of her
lover the king's son maybe there's a
parallel with this king Ezekiel or maybe
the kingly authority figure of the
hilltop Daryl eventually losing the son
figure Henry out of Henry's love for the
enemy of the state Lydia or maybe I'm
reading into things they also use music
to draw out the walkers a stereo playing
the mission mix tape kind of like the
guardians of the galaxy and opening a
volume to this could be a tactic that
they learned from the Savior's who
remember devised a fat lady car with
speakers blasting opera to draw away
walkers as Ezekiel and Carol cart home
with their bounty they pass this sign
with the symbol spray-painted on now my
guess is that this is alpha symbol
notice how it looks like an ace shape
with a horizontal line over it like the
Alpha and Omega symbols that appear in
Christian art perhaps this is a region
claimed by Alpha know you would think if
it was a warning they would just put up
a keep out sign so maybe this is a
marker for a planned border that the
whisperers intend to erect in the near
future kind of like the way the loggers
mark trees they intend to cut down with
spray paint now I won't get too much
into where this is all headed because
it's a huge spoiler from the comics but
obviously the show intends this to be a
foreboding sign at the top of this
episode remember Ezekiel boldly promised
that it'll all work out we
combined with all the good news about
Jerry's growing family with Nabila seem
to spell out doom the way Ezekiel's big
inspirational Kingdom speech did in
season 8 thankfully this story had a
happy ending but like many things are
with Ezekiel it may be a false victory
he and Carol Baskin both their bounties
the projector light glowing around them
as they encase their Charter in that
movie poster frame but both of these
bounties come from the world of movies
escapism the theaters called the Royal
or the Royale touching on Ezekiel's
fixation with regality and theatricality
and this could be a clue that Ezekiel's
hope for a brighter future could be
nothing more than a fantasy meanwhile
for Daryl Connie and Henry their bounty
tastes bitter sweet as well even with
the rescue of friends and the promise of
new life at the hilltop they can't live
with the idea of surrendering Lydia to
such an inhumane Society the bounty they
seek is something larger more elusive
justice but not dog dogs just coming
along for a good time dogs the best but
here's my question what do you think
went down between the communities that
led to Michonne's charter never getting
signed comment down below with your
thoughts and thanks again to Philo
sponsor this video and really made a
return weekly coverage of The Walking
Dead possible Philo is a streaming
service with over 50 channels including
AMC and Comedy Central a bunch of others
it's really the easiest way to watch The
Walking Dead you can start watching
within seconds and there's unlimited
recording you can save as many shows as
you want
Philo's available on Apple TV Roku
Android iOS fire TV it's simple it's
affordable only $20 a month for all this
content you can essentially save $100 as
much from your cable bill Philo is the
best solution to stay cord free and
commitment free he does especially offer
for you guys the first 50 new rockstars
fanta sign up using our link will get
their first month for free just visit
WWF Aiello TV slash new rock stars
that's pH Aiello TV slash new rockstars
and follow me on twitter and instagram @
ee vas and subscribe to this channel and
subscribe to our podcast where you
listen to podcasts thanks for watching
and special shout out to Samantha Morgan
for playing now for like Foghorn Leghorn
Aussie Aussie I'm here for my daughter